لكن
[موسيقى]
الالات مش متصبه بالمرض مش بنحتاج نعزلها
عن بعضها البعض علشان نحميها من اي خطر
ومش بتحتاج اجازات من الشغل الكلام اللي
فات ده مش كلامي ده كلام دانييل
الاقتصاد بكليه الملك اللندنيه وصاحب
الكتاب الشهير عالم بلا عمل تكنولوجيا
والاتمته وكيف ينبغي ان نرد والباحث
الرئيسي بمعهد اخلاقيات الذكاء الاصطناعي
في جامعه
في معهد كامل عند الجماعه الرايقين في
اوروبا عن اخلاقيات وقيم الذكاء الاصطناعي
زي ما شفته في الانترو كده انا بقى لي
فتره بلعب مع شات لا اكيد كتير منكم عارفه
ويمكن جربوا الفتره اللي فاتت لكن سريعا
كده للي مش عارفه منكم
الدردشه من انتاج شركه
في نوفمبر اللي فات 2022 هو تابع لاسره جي
بي تي ثري الكريمه ودي مجموعه من النماذج
اللغويه الاليه اللي بتستخدم تقنيات
التعلم العميق مع قواعد بيانات هائله
علشان ينتج نصوص مطوله ومتنوعه شبه اللي
احنا بنكتبه كبشر فانا قلت اختبر قدرته دي
ورحت قلت له حاول يكتب سكريبت حلقه من
حلقات المخ بالاقتصادي عن موضوع معين
والنتيجه كانت سيئه فعلا ولا تستحق العرض
فقلت ابسط الموضوع واساله شويه اسئله
ودردشت معاه في موضوعات مختلفه اقتصاديه
والحقيقه اجابات وبرضو كانت اجابات ذكاء
اصطناعي فعلا ما فيش فيها اي لمحه من
لمحات الموهبه والابداع اجابات جافه
اكاديميه تليق بقاعده بيانات كبيره اليه
مليانه معلومات مع زيرو تحليل وتركيب
وتناسق ابداعي
صفر يلا غور في داهيه طبعا ده لا يقلل من
قدرات البوت اللي بيقدم بشكل هايل جدا في
مهام تسهيل البحث وتبسيط المعلومات
المعقده وتوفير البيانات وتوليد بعض
الافكار والحقيقه ان ده برضو هراء
البروفيسور
استاذ الاقتصاد والتكنولوجيا المعلومات في
جامعه ستانفورد اللي شبه برامج الذكاء
الاصطناعي التوليدي بانها زي الاله
الحاسبه الخاصه بالكاتب لكن عاوزين نطمن
كلنا ونحاول مع بعض نجاوب على السؤال اللي
بيتجدد وبينتشر جدا جدا كل ما يطلع ترند
جديد يخص الذكاء الاصطناعي او في اوساط
تعلم الاله ماشي السؤال المهم البروفيسور
وغيره بيحاولوا يجاوبوا عليه وشغل العالم
هو هل الاتمته هتقضي على وظائف كتير مننا
وهل الذكاء الاصطناعي جاي علشان يقعدنا
كلنا في البيوت من غير شغل يعني السيناريو
المرعب ده موجود بالفعل حاليا في واحده من
اكبر شركات العالم وهي شركه امازون اللي
سرحت في اللي لسه خلصان ده 18 الف عامل من
قوتها البالغه اكتر من مليون ونص عامل في
مختلف القطاعات امازون بحسب تصريحات كيف
تعود الرئيس التنفيذيه لشركه اداره الاصول
اركان بتقول ان امازون حاليا بتضيف الف
روبوت يوميا لقوتها العامله وعندها حاليا
اكتر من نص مليون روبوت وبتتوقع ان عدد
روبوتات امازون هيتجاوز عدد العاملين في
2030 هنا لازم نسال شويه اسئله مهمه جدا
هل الكلام ده يخصنا اصلا ولا دي مشاكل
العالم الاول واحنا كدول ناميه ملناش دعوه
بيها ولو ازتكاء الاصطناعي هياخد وظائفنا
فعلا فازاي ده هيحصل وايه هي الوظائف
المهدده اكتر من غيرها هل التهديد ده
بيطول كل المهن وايه شكل سوق العمل اللي
هتخلقوا التقنيات الجديده دي وازاي نقدر
نستعد لكم اشخاص دي عينه من الاسئله
المهمه والمثيره اللي هنتكلم عليها في
حلقه النهارده بس قبل ما نبدا بفكركم
بالنسبه اللي جنب دي دي نسبه مشاهدينا
اللي مش مشتركين في القناه في يناير
اشتركوا مهم جدا وبيطور من شغلنا لما
بتشترك انت بتقول اليوتيوب ببساطه المحتوى
ده عاجبني فيظهروا لناس اكتر في كل العالم
بفكركم برضو ان كل حلقاتنا اللي فاتت
وترجمه للغه الانجليزيه فما تنسوش
تشاركوها مع اصحابكم الاجانب تعرفوهم على
القناه يلا بينا نشوف قصص الاتمته والذكاء
الاصطناعي الاحتمالي قعدنا في بيوتنا ده
انا اشرف ابراهيم ده المقبل الاقتصادي
[موسيقى]
واحده من اهم لغات البرمجه دلوقتي هي لغه
بايثون انا شخصيا بفكر اتعلمها لانها من
اللغات البرمجه الاكثر استخداما في تعلم
الاله والذكاء الاصطناعي حرفيا بتجهزك
للمستقبل وعلى فكره في مواقع عربيه بتقدم
دورات شامله باللغه العربيه زي اكاديميه
حاسوب حاسوب بتقدم دورات في معظم مجالات
البرمجه وتطوير التطبيقات بيبداوا معك من
الصفر وبيطبقوا عملي وبالتالي هتنفذ
مشاريع حقيقيه وهتقدم شغلك ده في اي
مقابلات عمل لو عايز تشتغل حر لاين هسيبهم
عندهم مواقع خمسات ومستقل اللي بيعتبروا
اكبر منصات العمل الحر في الوطن العربي
فحيساعدوك تشتغل والحمد لله قدرنا ناخذ
منهم كوبون خصم ب 100 دولار لاول 10
هيشتركوا في اي كورس استخدموا كوبون الخصم
اللي ظهر قدامكم على الشاشه ده وهتلاقوه
تحت الفيديو وتعليقات فيسبوك برده
ركزوا بقى معايا يا جماعه دي مش المره
الاولى اللي هنشوف فيها حاله الهلع والخوف
ده بسبب تهديدات الاتمته لوظائفنا
واعمالنا الحقيقه الموضوع قديم شويه
تحديدا ظهر سنه 1580 لما الملكه اليزابيث
الاولى ملكه انجلترا رفضت منح براءه
اختراع لماكينه الخياطه الاليه
اللي اخترعها طب ليه لان اليزابيث قلقت من
تاثير الاله على وظائف ومستوى معيشه
العاملين في صناعه نسيج الجوارب اليدويه
علشان كده هنلاقي ان احتجاجات عمال صناعه
النسيج البريطانيين وصناع الحرير
الفرنسيين على ظهور الات الماسك في بدايه
القرن 19 كانت من المعالم المميزه للثوره
الصناعيه الاوروبيه وده بيقول لنا قد ايه
المخاوف من خطوره الالات على التوصيف
قديمه متكرره والقرن ال20 تحديدا عرف
محطات كثيره في مسيره التحول
ظهرت معها دعوات اكتر بتحذر من توغل
الالات وتاثيرها على وظائفنا اهم الموجات
دي حصلت بعد الحرب العالميه الثانيه في
الخمسينات لما مصانع كثير بدات تتحول
للالات وتستغنى عن البشر وعلى راسها مصنع
المحركات الايقونه لشركه فول العملاقه
اللي تحول مصنع الي بشكل شبه كامل في بروك
بارك في وده ادى لفتان عشرات الالاف من
العمال لوظائفهم ودخل الاقتصاد الامريكي
في مرحله كاسات كبيره اتعرف التاريخيا
باسم جساد الاتمته او اتوميشن وقتها خرج
الرئيس الامريكي
واعلن ان الاتمته هي التحدي الاكبر
للوظائف
يعني كله سواد كده يا اشرف الحقيقه لا
مختصر تاريخ الاتمته السريع جدا ده مثير
للتفاؤل ما تستغربوش لان كل ده اثاره
النهائيه على اسواق العمل كانت كويسه جدا
واجمالي فرص العمل البشريه لانتجتها
التقنيات دي على المدى الطويل كانت افضل
بكتير من فرص العمل اللي دمرتها وبعض
الوظائف دي وظائف جديده تماما ما كانتش
موجوده قبل ما تظهر التقنيات دي نسال بقى
السؤال الاساسي هل الذكاء الاصطناعي
بتطوره الحالي هياخد وظائفنا الحقيقه ده
سؤال صعب جدا ومقوم خناقه بين فريقين اشرف
واحد بينتمي فعليا وحكم دراسته وشغلي
لفريق من الاتنين دول الفريق الاول هو
فريق التقنيين رجاله وادي السيليكون زي
ايلون ماسك والصوره عندهم غايه في السواد
وكلامهم دايما بالشكل ده يا جماعه استعدوا
روبوتات والذكاء الاصطناعي جايين ياخدوا
اماكنكم والتكنولوجيا مش بس هتخلق جيوش من
العطلين عن العمل ولكن كمان نسبه كبيره من
الناس دي هتكون غير قابله للتوظيف في
اماكن ثانيه لان خبراتها وتعليمها
وقدراتها بعيده جدا عن متطلبات اسواق
العمل المستقبليه اللي هتحتاج مؤهلات
مختلفه واعلى بكتير من اللي عند العاطلين
الاخطر كمان بالنسبه لفريق التقنيين انه
على عكس الموجات السابقه للتكنولوجيا
واللي كانت بتاثر بشكل رئيسي على وظائف
ذوي الياقات الزرقاء من العماله غير
المهره والمهره فالموجه اللي جايه هتاثر
كمان على وظائف ذوي الياقات البيضاء من
العاملين في المكاتب يعني لو دكتور او او
محامي او مدير فوظيفتك انت كمان ما عدتش
في ده كلام التقنيين الفريق التاني بقى هو
فريق علماء الاقتصاد الرجاله الهاديه اللي
قاعدين بيسمعوا لتحذيرات التقنيين في كل
مكان ومختلفين معها جدا وبيقولوا ان دي مش
اول مره نشوفه ملاحظه التهديد ده ان
الالاف هتاخد وظائف البشر طيب علماء
الاقتصاد هادين ومتفائلين على اي اساس ايه
حجتهم يعني علشان افهمكم ده خلوني اضرب
لكم مثال مهم جدا متعلق بالحاسب الالي او
الكمبيوتر الشخصي اللي ممكن تبقى بتتفرج
عليا منه دلوقتي حالا اللي قدامكم دي
دراسه لمؤسسه العالميه للاستشارات بتقول
في جزء منها ببساطه ان الكمبيوتر لما ظهر
تسبب في نحو ثلاثه ونصف مليون وظيفه في
الولايات المتحده محاسبين على موظفي
السكرتاريه على عمال الاله الكاتبه وغيرهم
عدد الوظائف البشريه دي الحاسب مسحه
باستيكه امتى بين سنه 1980 و2015 طيب ايه
للتفاؤل في اللي بتقوله ده التفاؤل هنا ان
نفس تكنولوجيا الحواسيب انشات اكتر من 19
مليون وظيفه جديده في الفتره نفسها يعني
اكتر من خمس اضعاف الوظائف اللي لغتها
وظائف جديده في قطاعات كتير من اول تصنيع
اجهزه الكمبيوتر نفسها لصناعه البرامج
والتطبيقات المرتبطه بها وصولا للتجاره
الالكترونيه والبيع من خلال الانترنت خدوا
بالكم احنا هنا بنتكلم عن رقم ضخم جدا
بنتكلم عن حوالي خمس لعدد الاجمالي تقريبا
للوظائف اللي خلقها الاقتصاد الامريكي طول
الفتره دي واللي كانت اكتر من 87 مليون
وظيفه يعني تقريبا وظيفه من كل خمس او ست
وظائف كانت سبب فيها طفره الحواسيب تفاؤل
فريق الاقتصاديين ده يخلينا نسال سؤال مهم
جدا ازاي التكنولوجيا اللي بتحل محل
العماله البشريه ممكن تنشئ وظائف جديده
ركزوا معايا شويه في الجزء ده علشان مهم
جدا صحيح ان اي تكنولوجيا جديده بتدمر
الوظائف اللي هي جايه تحل محلها وتعملها
احسن وادق لكنها في نفس الوقت بتخرج لنا
بشكل مباشر مجموعه وظائف تانيه متعلقه
بالتكنولوجيا دي نفسها يعني مثلا الالات
اللي حلت محل العمال في المصانع دمرت
وظائف العمال اه لكنها خلقت وظائف تانيه
زي تصنيع الالات دي وتطويرها وصيانتها
والتجاره فيها كمبيوتر مثلا دمر وظائف بعض
المحاسبين والسكرتاريه اللي كانوا بينفذوا
مهام بدائيه شويه لكنه انشا عالم كامل
يشمل ابتكار وصناعه وتطوير الشاشات
والمعالجات والمكونات التقنيه بخلاف جانب
سوفت وير الخاص بالبرامج والتطبيقات لكن
الحقيقه الحكايه ما بتقفش عند كده احد
الاهداف الرئيسيه لادخال اي تكنولوجيا
جديده هو سياده الانتاجيه والانتاجيه
ببساطه هي مقدار السلع والخدمات اللي
بينتجها كل عامل في كل ساعه من العمل
المصنع او القطاع اللي بتزيد انتاجيته
بيكون عنده فرص اكبر للتوسع وبالتالي خلق
وظائف جديده زياده الانتاجيه برضو المفروض
يعني معناها اجور اعلى للعمال واسعار اقل
للسلع يعني القدره الشرائيه اكبر وبالتالي
دورات انتاج جديده لتلبيه الطلب على
السلعه دي يعني شغل اكتر ومكاسب افضل
وهكذا ومعناها برضو اوقات عمل اقل واوقات
فراغ اكتر في الاقتصادات المتقدمه مثلا
حاليا متوسط ساعات العمل الاسبوع للفرد
انخفضت بنسبه 50% مقارنه بالبدايات القرن
العشرين وزادت ايام الاجازات المدفوعه
وكمان زاد عدد العاملين بدوام جزئي اللي
بيشتغلوا اوقات اقل طب يعني احنا نصدق مين
دلوقتي بتوع التكنولوجيا المتشائمين اللي
بقولوا لنا كله رايح ولا الاقتصاديين اللي
شايفين الدنيا كويسه واننا هنلاقي وظائف
احسن باجور افضل واوقات عمل اقل الحقيقه
ما نقدرش ناخذ جانب واحد ونعمل التاني
هقول لكم ازاي التاريخ بيقف مع كلام
الاقتصاديين وبيقول لنا ان الثورات
الاتمته كانت نتائجها جيده على المدى
الطويل لكننا ما نقدرش نتجاهل ابدا كلام
التقنيين اللي بيحذرونا من المره دي
وان موجه الاكمته اعلى من الكل لان لهم
اسبابهم الوجيهه برضو احنا لما بنتكلم عن
توغل الالات حاليا مش بنتكلم عن مجموعه من
الماكينات والاجهزه التقليديه اللي بتقوم
بعمال يدويه مكرره في المصانع زي ما كان
الحال زمان لكننا بنتكلم عن ذكاء الي عنده
القدره على التعلم من قواعد بيانات مهوله
وقادر يقود سيارات وطائرات وتاجر في
البورصه ويشخص بعض الامراض ويساعد في وصف
ادويه العلاجها وفي بعض الاحيان بيخوض
محادثات مرتبه بكفاءه عاليه جدا ده معناه
ان النطاق الوظائف المهدده بقى واسع جدا
عن المراحل التاريخيه السابقه من الاخر
كده احنا مش بنتكلم عن عشرات او حتى مئات
الالاف من عماله المصانع او اصحاب الوظائف
العاديه لكننا بنتكلم دلوقتي عن ملايين
المهندسين والمحاسبين ومقدمي الخدمات
الماليه مزوده رعايه الصحيه وغيرهم اللي
هم معظم خليجي الجامعات حاليا تقنيين
المتشائمين بيحذرونا من التطور السريع
للمعالجات الحاسوبيه والذكاء الاصطناعي
والشبكات العصبيه الاصطناعيه اسرع بكتير
من توقعاتنا يعني التوقعات اللي موجوده
النهارده ممكن ببساطه تتغير 180 درجه
السنه اللي جايه سنه 2004 على سبيل المثال
في دراسه مشهوره توقعت ان الذكاء
الاصطناعي مش هيكون قادر ابدا على فهم
خطابه لغه البشر عشان نتواصل معهم طبعا مش
محتاجه اقول لكم دلوقتي الدراسه دي مكانها
ايه لانه حاليا كل واحد مننا معاه في
تليفونه العادي جدا مساعد صوتي الكتروني
كامل ممكن يطلب منه اي حاجه بصوته ويفهموا
كويس ويتجاوب معه hello
open يوتيوب بليز ok google
تقنين برضو بيقولوا لنا ان الابتكارات
الحديثه ما بتخلقش وظائف بنفس القدر اللي
كانت بتخلعوا زمان ازاي ده يا اشرف خليني
اضرب لكم مثال بسيط فاكرين شركه بلوك
باستر الامريكيه اللي كانت بتقدم خدمات
تاجير الافلام والعاب الفيديو المنزليه
الشركه دي كانت في قمه نجاحها سنه 2004
وركزوا معايا في الارقام دي كانت بتوظف في
السنه دي 84 الف شخص في اكتر من 9000 متجر
حول العالم وحققت ايرادات حوالي 6 مليار
دولار الشركه طبعا زي ما حضراتكم عارفين
اعلنت افلاسها سنه 2010 بعد ما فشلت في
التاقلم مع متغيرات السوق وفضلت نايمه على
ودانها لانه ببساطه محدش بقى بياجر افلام
فيديو بعد انتشار شركات البث المباشر زي
نتفليكس شركه نتفليكس عملاق البث اللي
قامت على انقاض بلوك باستر حققت السنه
اللي فاتت 2022
ايرادات وصلت ل 31.6 مليار دولار بكام
موظف بقى حوالي 13 الف موظف بس يعني اكتر
من خمس اضعاف ارباح
باقل من سدس عدد الموظفين تقريبا الشاهد
من كلام فريق التقنيين ان النسبه بين
الارباح اللي بتدخلها تقنيات الجديده وبين
اعداد فرص العمل اللي بتوفرها بتقل بمرور
الزمن صحيح التقنيات الحديثه ممكن تكون
بتحسن حياتنا لكنها ما بتخلقش وظائف بنفس
القدر طب ايه بقى الوظائف المعرضه للخطر
سنه 2017 في دراسه مهمه جدا عملها عملاق
المحاسبه والاستشارات البريطاني رئيس ووتر
هاوس كوبرز الدراسه دي تنبات ان 30% من
الوظائف في بريطانيا وتمانيه في امريكا
و35% في المانيا
و21% في اليابان معرضه لخطر الاتمته او
التحول الالي بحلول سنه 2030 هنا بقى سؤال
مهم ازاي خبراء برايس ووتر حددوا الوظائف
والقطاعات المعرضه للخطر اللي حصل ان
الباحثين في برايس ووتر صنفوا مهام كل
وظيفه تحت خمس اق مهام يدويه وروتينيه
وحسابيه وتواصليه ولغويه وعن طريق التصنيف
ده مقارنته مع قدرات الالات والذكاء
الاصطناعي المعروفه قدروا يدوا لكل وظيفه
سكور معين على مؤشر الابتمته يعني ببساطه
كده كل ما كانت وظيفتك بتحتوي على مهام
ممكن تقوم بها الالات بسهوله زي المهام
اليدويه او الروتينيه او بعض المهام
الحسابيه كل ما كنت في خطر وعلى الجهه
التانيه بقى كل ما كانت وظيفتك بتحتوي على
مهام اداريه او تواصليه او ابداعيه كل من
خطر بخصوصها كان اقل وهكذا المنهجيه دي
تقريبا لكن بشكل اكثر تفصيلا شويه
استخدمتها دراسه تانيه لمؤسسه ماكنسي صدرت
في مايو 2018 بعنوان تحول المهارات
الاتمته ومستقبل قوى العمل الباحثين في
مكانزي حللوا 25 مهاره مطلوبه في سوق
العمل وصنفوها تحت خمس قدرات رئيسيه
مهارات يدويه وحرفيه ومعرفيه بدائيه او
بسيطه عرفيه متقدمه واجتماعيه وعاطفيه
واخيرا مهارات تقنيه وقارنوا بين ساعات
العمل المتاح لكل نوع من المهارات دي سنه
2016 وعدد الساعات المتوقعه لها سنه 2030
والنتائج زي ما حضراتكم توقعتم اكيد ان
الاستبدال هيحصل بشكل رئيسي في الوظائف
المعتمده على المهارات الحرفيه والمهارات
المعرفيه البسيطه في حين ان الوظائف اللي
محتاجه مهارات اجتماعيه وتواصليه ومهارات
تقنيه مش بس هتكون في امان لكن هيزيد
عليها الطلب بشكل ملحوظ او بصينا للارقام
هنكتشف مثلا ان العمال في اوروبا وامريكا
عضو03 مليار ساعه عمل في اداء اعمال يدويه
وحرفيه سنه 2016 الرقم ده متوقع ينخفض 174
مليار ساعه سنه 2030 بنسبه انخفاض 14%
الفئه دي بتضم مجموعه واسعه جدا من المهن
زي اصحاب المهن الحرفيه المختلفه
والسواقين وميكانيكيه السيارات وعمال
الطعام ملل المصانع وحراس الامن وغيرها
ولو انتقلنا للمهام المعرفيه البسيطه
هنلاقي ان عدد ساعات العمل هينخفض من 115
مليار ساعه في 2016 لسبعه وتسعين مليار
ساعه بس في 2030 بنسبه انخفاض 15% والفئه
دي بتضم وظائف زي الكاشير وموظفي خدمه
العملاء ومدخله البيانات اما فئه المهارات
المعرفيه المتقدمه اللي بتضم وظائف زي
الاطباء والمحاسبين والمحللين الماليين
والمحامين والكتاب بمختلف انواعهم
واحصائيه الموارد البشريه وكمان الفنانين
والموسيقيين فدول الساعات المتاحه لهم مش
هتنخفض لكنها برضو مش هتزيد كتير من 140 ل
151 مليار ساعه سنه 2030 فدول وضعهم مستقر
نسبيا وفقا لنتائج دي المحظوظين بقى فهم
الجماعه اصحاب المهارات التواصليه
والعاطفيه زي المديرين والتنفيذيين
والمعلمين والمدربين ومخططات الاعمال
وكمان مندوب المبيعات والتسويق الجماعه
دول الذكاء الاصطناعي لسه مشترك في
مناطقهم وبالتالي الطلب عليهم هيزيد
وساعات عملهم هترتفع من 119 مليار ساعه ل
148 مليار ساعه بزياده 24% واخيرا معانا
ليفل الوحش وحيتانا المستقبل وهم اصحاب
المهارات التقنيه مطوره تطبيقات واخصائيين
الشبكات ومحلل البيانات المتقدمين
والمهندسين خبراء الروبوتات والذكاء
الاصطناعي ودول هترتفع حصتهم في سوق العمل
من 73 مليار ساعه ل113 مليار ساعه في 2030
بزياده مهوله قدرها 55% تقريبا طب ايه
اللي بيخلي نسبه الوظائف الاحتمال تدمر
بسبب التكنولوجيا تختلف من دوله لدوله
يعني ايه اللي يفرق امريكا عن بريطانيا
والمانيا عن اليابان وايه يفرق كل دوله عن
مصر والسعوديه والجزائر والمغرب وغيرهم من
دول العربيه مثلا بصوا يا جماعه في عوامل
كتير جدا
في وتيره اتمته اي اقتصاد اولها طبيعه
الاقتصاد نفسه يعني مثلا متطلبات الاتمته
في الاقتصادات الصناعيه الكبرى زي المانيا
واليابان مختلفه عن الاقتصادات الخدميه زي
الولايات المتحده وبريطانيا وحتى في
الاقتصادات المتشابهه طبيعه القطاع نفسه
بتعمل فرق كبير لو اخذنا على سبيل المثال
قطاعيه الخدمات الماليه في امريكا
وبريطانيا هنلاقي دراسه كلمتكم عنها من
شويه بتتوقع ان معدل الاتمته في القطاع ده
في امريكا هتوصل ل61 في حين انه هيكون 32%
بس في بريطانيا يعني النص تقريبا السبب في
كده هو الفرق في تركيبه القطاع نفسه في
الدولتين متوسط مستوى التعليم في القطاع
ده في بريطانيا اعلى من نظيره في امريكا
ده معناه ان معظم العاملين في بريطانيا هم
من المحترفين اللي بيشتغلوا بشكل اساسي
على اسواق المال العالميه في لندن بينما
في الولايات المتحده جزء كبير من العاملين
في القطاع شغالين على مستوى محل منخفض
وبيحتاجه اقل وبالتالي سهل استبدالهم
لصالح الالات الذكيه القصه نفسها بتنطبق
على المانيا او اليابان الاتنين اقتصادات
صناعيه لكن قابليه القطاع الصناعي
الالماني للاثمته اعلى بكتير من نظيره
الياباني وده لان العمال اليابانيين
بيقوموا بالفعل بمهام يدويه حاليا اقل من
اقرنهم في المانيا الخبر الكويس بالنسبه
لنا في دولنا العربيه بقى ان وتيره التحول
الالي في قطاعات كتير هتكون عندنا ابطا
شويه من الاقتصادات الكبرى زي امريكا
وبريطانيا والمانيا ده مش معناه اننا
محصنين لكن معناه ان العاصفه لو قامت
هتوصل لنا متاخر شويه وده هيدينا وقت اكبر
للتاقلم مع المتغيرات سواء للاشخاص زيه زي
حضراتكم اللي محتاجين نسلحوا نفسهم
بالمهارات المناسبه لسوق العمل المتغير او
الدول اللي محتاجه تاخد اجراءات استباقيه
تحسبا لتداعيات التحول ده لحد هنا انا
خلصت كلامي وفي النهايه هطلب من حضراتكم
طلب يا ريت كل واحد في التعليقات يش مهنته
او تخصصه ورايه اذا كانت وظيفته الحاليه
او المنتظره معرضه للخطر بسبب الذكاء
الاصطناعي ولا لا وليه ما تنسوش تشتركوا
في دوره تعلم البرمجه بلغه بايثون من
اكاديميه حاسوب علشان تكونوا جزء من
المستقبل بتاع الذكاء الاصطناعي هتابع كل
تعليقاتكم ما تنسوش تشتركوا في القناه زي
ما اتفقنا ويا ريت لو عجبتكم الحلقه دي
تعملوا لايك وشير للفيديو واهم حاجه تحكوا
لاصحابكم وحبايبكم عننا يمكن يستفيدوا
سلام
[موسيقى]